[Music]
Disney stories come with a lot of life
lessons but sometimes they also teach us
totally wrong things stay tuned to find
out the lesson that's extremely harmful
for people's emotional development if
you're new here hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
let's check out 10 lies Disney taught
kids growing up
Pocahontas married John Smith let's
start this video off by debunking one of
the biggest things Disney got wrong and
we're definitely not happy about it in
Pocahontas Disney decided to turn a sad
story into something totally romantic
when the real truth is far from anything
Disney movies have taught us and while
we're on the subject there are also no
raccoons in the real-life Pocahontas
story which was told by Pocahontas own
tribe
she was probably under a watchful eye
more than any other child there that
being said Pocahontas was about nine or
ten when John Smith and the English
colonists arrived in the village and the
two were never romantically involved
ever and according to the historical
accounts
Pocahontas would never ask to spare
Smith's life because children weren't
allowed to attend any rituals that were
similar to the where oh and ceremony
Pocahontas did end up marrying a young
warrior but it's definitely not a
romantic story she married John Rolfe
and it's not clear whether it was really
out of love since she wasn't allowed to
see her family but you won't find any of
this in a Disney story cute animals are
automatically friendly so let's taco
about something else that Disney always
manages to get wrong unless the animal
is a villain or looks particularly ugly
and flawed Disney makes you believe that
all animals are automatically friendly
and that you can automatically walk up
to any animal and pet them as much as
you want
adults have probably learned that this
is just simply not true we all know
feral animals or even animals who aren't
used to human contact take a while to
get used to their surroundings but it
seems like characters like Jasmine have
no issues with pet Tigers or George of
the jungle doesn't really have any
concerns with animals as long as they're
not his biggest enemy go on if you pet a
cat you don't know from the street we
bet it would have no issues scratching
you even some dogs would allow you to
pet them even though they seem friendly
although Disney has a lot of love when
it comes to animal
it only usually shows creatures like
hyenas as completely mean and incapable
of being friendly the truth is this
could apply to any animal you meet we
all know chihuahuas are incredibly cute
and tiny but they're also the ones that
can be the first ones to attack you
balloons can make you fly Disney movies
and cartoons how defied gravity in many
ways and showed us that it actually is
possible to get up in the air with just
a single balloon if you've ever tried to
tie a balloon around you you know that
statement is pretty fast but yet we see
cartoon characters being lifted up by a
single balloon again and again while
something like this would definitely be
nice it's just not possible in real life
it would require several balloons and
probably a lot of wind blowing in the
right direction to actually make that
work although this would indeed be a
magical experience we can't imagine how
hard it would be to keep an eye on kids
they'd probably just fly away the moment
they grabbed on we're glad the laws of
gravity are able to defy this Disney
logic even though flying with a balloon
would be pretty cool well we always have
a hot air balloon option getting kissed
by a stranger is romantic everyone
dreams of love at first sight and that
first magical kiss that sets off
fireworks and start your happily ever
after
well the reality is a little bit
different let's look at Sleeping Beauty
for example the story makes it seem that
every girl wants to be kissed by a
stranger because it's a kiss that will
change her life forever by the time
girls grow up they realize that kisses
by complete strangers just aren't that
attractive as a matter of fact if a girl
never wanted the kiss in the first place
this is totally unacceptable and yet
Disney movies made us romanticize the
idea that someday a total stranger will
sweep us off our feet and change our
lives forever in real life most
strangers have a very different agenda
and very few can actually be held to the
same standard as the Disney men who all
seemed to be pretty good kissers call us
jealous but we think moments like that
very rarely happen in real life and if
they do they often get turned into a
Disney movie anyways because they're so
rare we're often taught to not talk to
strangers when were younger but that
turns into don't kiss strangers when we
realize just how uncomfortable that is
most of the time
jungles call for an adventure George if
the jungle really made
to see like jungles always represent an
adventure and a chance to swing off the
branches explore new areas and pet some
exotic animals well that's all good in
the disney world it doesn't work as well
and smooth and reality real life jungles
are hard to survive especially if you
come unprepared and are unfamiliar with
the environment you're in the jungle is
full of rare creatures we don't know
much about and they can attack you at
any moment if you're not careful on top
of that not knowing which plants are
edible or not could poison you in no
time
jungles are also absolutely huge and
without the right kind of navigation
most get completely lost and dehydrated
within 24 hours you could also find
several animals that normally look cute
but they can be extremely poisonous if
you pick it up it's also highly unlikely
that wild animals will eventually
consider you a part of their family and
raise you like one of their own not
being prepared in the jungle can easily
mean you'll risk your life and it's
definitely not the adventure most Disney
movies show us it is obsession over
someone is cute we've seen it time and
time again that obsessing over a person
and desperately wanting someone to love
you is considered okay in Disney movies
Ariel's obsession is considered cute
even Gaston from Beauty and the Beast
it's considered funny and not at all
creepy by most people and [ __ ] from
Lady and the [ __ ] is clearly a
womanizer who pretty much obsessed with
everyone Disney also often highlights
stalking of a specific character as
funny especially if the stalker gets to
sing a catchy song about their weird
obsession not being able to give people
their privacy and watching their every
move is often considered illegal and can
be easily punishable in real life it
also doesn't mean that person will
automatically like you and want to be
with you especially if you take your
obsession too far and don't respect
their feelings so next time you think
going too far with liking a person and
focusing on their every single move is
okay think again to avoid getting
yourself in trouble with the law
lying is okay some popular Disney
stories try to romanticize lying as
something that's okay to do especially
if it means it'll get you the girl or
the man you want the lessons of Aladdin
were originally supposed to teach us
that lying is not okay but that notion
gets completely lost because Aladdin
lies his way into Jasmine's heart for
way too long
even
Jeannie knows he should tell her the
truth and we all know what Jasmine's
reaction was like when she found out the
truth telling white lies is okay but
telling big lies that make you seem like
you're someone you're not just so you
can win another person's heart is
definitely not okay it means you're
practically manipulating the person into
being with you even though you can't
promise the things you're originally
promised it's always best to be honest
and let the person to your true spirit
and soul rather than convincing them
you're someone you're not because let's
be honest that never turns out well if
you want someone to love you for who you
are you should be who you are right from
the beginning otherwise they might think
you've tricked them all pirates are
funny and cool if there's anything the
Pirates of the Caribbean taught us that
pirates are naturally funny and
extremely charming but not only that
they're also very good-looking
especially if they look anything like
Jack Sparrow being a pirate is
considered cool but modern Pirates do
exist and they're anything but cool or
funny being a pirate is actually quite
dangerous
even though Pirates of the Caribbean
taught us that pirates have an amazing
sense of humor the truth is pirates
still exists in some parts of the world
and they're definitely not ready to be
sarcastic or have a funny conversation
with you Southeast Asian seas are still
subject to a lot of pirate raids and
anyone that has ever come in contact
with a pirate can tell you their sense
of humor is far from sarcastic Hollywood
movies try to glamorize pirates but the
truth is if you ever see a pirate you
should run as fast as you can because it
might just save your life don't wait for
them to be charming or while you with
their sarcasm because it most likely
won't happen and definitely don't wait
to see if they're anything like Jack
Sparrow you'll always feel extreme
emotions Maine Disney characters we all
love and admire often come up with
simple emotions you're easily able to
tell apart when they're sad they cry and
when they're happy they smile characters
that come with more emotions than that
are often considered evil especially if
their feelings come with a negative
connotation but people very rarely feel
extreme emotions at all times and more
than often it's very hard to tell
whether you're happy or sad especially
when you grow up and you're exposed to
more and more stressful situations it
takes a while to actually analyze what
you feel and why you're feeling those
things is
especially if you're the type of person
that often experiences anxiety
depression or other feelings that are
much harder to analyze or even point out
in Disney movies we very rarely see a
character jump from one emotion to
another but in real life this happens
more than often and sometimes it's not
even something we can easily control
processing your emotions can be
extremely frustrating but according to
Disney all good people ever feel is
being happy or being sad all other
emotions belong to villains and those
that come with a hidden agenda they're
always as extreme as possible everything
has a happy ending if there's anything
we learn through Disney movies and their
characters is that everything and
everyone always has a happy ending the
sentence that the character lived
happily ever after is so normal no one
ever acknowledges that there's no such
thing as constant happiness without any
issues we all know that real life is
much more complicated than that life
comes with things and challenging
moments that are totally out of control
and they can happen at any time while
people can definitely be happy as a
state of mind saying that their life
will be left completely without any
problems whatsoever isn't true it
doesn't prepare us for the true ups and
downs life often throws our way and it
definitely doesn't highlight enough
struggles things like marriage can bring
according to Disney finding the love of
your life and marrying someone is the
end of your story and your purpose in
life everything that happens after is
considered to be a happy ending while
this might have been true hundreds of
years ago the modern society also
acknowledges that it's not the only way
people should be able to live their life
don't wait until a happy ending comes to
you instead make the best of every
situation that comes your way that's it
for our video don't forget to subscribe
to our channel and check out 10 times
Disney lied straight to your face from
our sister channel the taco see you next
time
[Music]